ladies and gentlemen hope you're doing
well welcome
back to another episode of coffeezilla
i'm your host in the 10 million dollar
studio
and uh as usual hello whoa the sun just
turned on
editor can i get my theme music please
wait what what is this no
not that the music my investigative
theme music dude
people watching okay sorry about that
got a little distracted guys today
we are learning about stocks with tick
tocks that's right and if you don't
like dumb rhymes you can go and kick
rocks
okay because i don't give a [ __ ]
bleep that out bleep that out well my
mom's watching probably dead
i'm i'm a good boy i'm a good boy who
doesn't break any of youtube's rules
but guys it used to be that if you
wanted to make a lot of money with the
stock market
you went and you got yourself a wealth
advisor and as we all know uh the great
robin hood broke down the barriers
and let any idiot with five bucks
go invest with the big boys right and so
all of a sudden
we said screw the regulators screw
people who know what they're doing
we're gonna create wall street bets the
next evolution
of stupidity okay people start blowing
up their entire accounts
overnight but there's a new brand of
idiocy going around it if you're not
up to speed with it please i'd love to
share with you the beautiful world
of tick tock investing let's go to the
board guys we got a lot to talk about
today okay
so we're just gonna cut right to the
chase okay try not to decapitate myself
with this um i swear one of these days
it's gonna do it guys if you aren't
subscribed
tic toc investors they curate a great
account of uh
all these guys if you're like me you
don't want to sit through
scroll through the tick tock thing you
want to see the curated version they do
a good job
uh quick shout out to them now let's
check this out
so what do we learn first because in
this video i want to go through
10 principles of finance as taught to us
by the tick tock investors now are these
good principles well i don't know
uh should you listen to them probably
not but we're gonna hear them anyways
right
because if we've learned anything it's
that sometimes
the dumbest people in the world have the
best ideas so you gotta open
open your mind which brings us to rule
number one coincidentally
rule number one is invite the pump into
your life that's right
the pump always guess respect the pump i
respect the pump in all assets
why because it's kind of like karma you
know the power of the pump always comes
back to you if you respect the pump of
other people it's it's
what what is he talking about dad
this guy's in a crypto and the pump is
when like
everyone rushes in at the same time like
a bunch of lemmings they all just go in
they
spike the price this is usually known to
be followed by
a dump traditionally especially in
places like crypto
where a lot of people lose a lot of
money but anyway we're gonna hear what
this guy thinks you gotta respect the
pop crazy but i have this belief
that whatever pumps you have to pay
respect because otherwise if you're like
oh my god guys if it pubs
you pay respect you you bow down you pay
respect to whatever pops guys that's
how it's how it works i don't admit the
rules this guy doesn't either it's karma
dude
this this this scam coin the scam coin
is pumping again
actually you are kind of rejecting
you're rejecting the pump from your life
maybe it's a bit
out there you know woo woo but we all
gotta believe in something and i do
believe in
this guy is going to the church of pop
the caption is people pay to listen to
this so i'm assuming
he's got some kind of like course or
something and people are
paying to hear this the power of the
pump
is kind of like you know let the pump be
with you i went to bed yesterday i told
you guys on twitter
made the puppy with you dude it's like
george this guy's the george lucas of
crypto
may the pump be with you guys hey listen
you know what he might be right
and the reason i say that is because you
know youtubers have their own pump too
this is
my social blade right here and as you
can see
we've been going through a bit of a pump
ourselves ever since we started
uploading daily uh so so respect the
pump guys
bow before the pump not a scam pump not
a scam ever you can't scam if it's a
pump
all right so what's rule number two of
tick tocks
you know stocks with tick tocks what is
it wait a second let me fix this
that's better here's my strategy in a
nutshell i see a stock going up and i
buy it
and i just watch it until it stops going
up and then i sell it and i do that over
and over and it pays for our whole
lifestyle
wait what he just admitted timing the
market
that's all he said he goes he goes guys
i i just buy low
and then i sell high whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa hold on
that's not a strategy a stock going up
and i buy it and i just watch it until
it stops going up
and then i sell it and i do look how he
look how he reacts to it
he's like duh look at look how smug he
is with this
up and then i sell it i just
i sell it what are you dumb i do that
over and over and it pays for our whole
lifestyle
that's what really pisses me off look if
he hadn't said that i wouldn't be mad
i'd be like i'd assume he's making
nothing but of course
he's got to claim yeah just you know
finding our whole lifestyle what do you
live in a shoebox
what kind of lifestyle are you really
funding here boss so rule number two i
guess
is buy low sell high i don't know what
kind of rule that is but okay
the next rule is going to tell you how
to take an account from 4k to 1 million
dollars
let's check it out turning 4 000 into a
million dollars this year and you're
gonna watch me do it
warren buffett once described compound
interest as a wonder of the world
you see me i love how they throw that in
by the way warren buffett
he's a real investor so the fact i know
him must mean i'm real
i'm an options day trader
[Music]
i'm going to find compound interest and
daydream to take this 4k into a million
dollars
what dude
you're literally quoting a guy who
totally disavows all that day trading
stuff
and then going yeah so like because
warren buffett says it i'm real but then
i'm doing what he tells everyone not to
do
i'm options day trading that's smart
warren buffett like could not speak out
morgan's
anyway it doesn't matter we're learning
guys i'm not here to criticize i'm here
to learn what am i doing dude i'm
thinking too hard about it i'm thinking
too much
so i guess rule number three right uh
options day trade like warren buffett
that's that's that's our role next rule
guys
creating passive income via penny stock
investing in the past week i've made 200
per day investing in the stock market
how here is about to absolutely blow up
come monday
just today alone it's gone up 72 meaning
if you had invested a thousand dollars
in the morning you would be closing out
the day with a 700
profit oh my gosh you can't go hides it
listen
this is like it's like basically
standing in front of a roulette and
after it hits
black you're like see if you just
invested in black you would have doubled
your money
it's like okay yeah now we know that's
not
you can lose money too i don't know so i
guess rule number four
um trade after you know the results of
the trade
that's rule number four on tick tock i
guess rule number five
really just woke up i don't go to hobbin
robin hood
about to get all this free money thank
you
guys sound like corpse husband dude get
a youtube channel you don't need to be
tick-tocking if we know anything about
youtube it's that you're going to get
millions of subs
for having this kind of voice here at
link in bio
i'm about to take a dab and [ __ ] yeah
get started
okay you're gonna get started by hitting
a dab and logging into robinhood
uh okay i don't know what what do we
roll five or six
editor put it i'm not i'm not even
following the rules they're so bad
rule whatever um
[Music]
wake and robin hood or something like
that roll six or whatever we're at now
just like that
made 300 for the day i gotta go make
more money in person
is this the same guys look at the same
guy i'm three days into this [ __ ] look
that's just that's only from today
i don't care i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing
at least he admitted it dude roll six
whatever rule we're on
you don't know what you're doing just go
in blindly invest this is how tick tocks
works
stocks with tick tocks this is how it
goes guys you don't need to know what
you're doing
here we go you guys want to play a game
let's manipulate the stock market whoa
buddy i spy with my little eye
somebody who's about to visit the
penitentiary
uh you don't start a public video with
let's hey guys you look around as if
you're afraid people are watching
as you're broadcasting to the whole
world and then you say hey guys
play a little game let's manipulate the
stock market
i guess that's rule seven manipulate the
stock market
okay next roll turn your 600
into 13 000. okay i'm skipping that roll
uh i'm arresting anyone who says stemi
you're arrested if you call the stimulus
check a stemi
right to jail no don't pass go right to
jail you
you go right to jail right to jail right
away
next roll
that's ripple they're gonna be
huge they're gonna be huge ripple will
be bigger than amazon when did he post
this
it looks like he post people are saying
he posted it december 15th hey
here's uh here here's a little dose of
fresh air for you buddy
look at this sec charges ripple and two
executives with
conducting 1.3 billion dollar
unregistered securities offering
oops that's rule 8 invest everything
into ripple
and then watch it tank overnight on
december 22nd
nice one dude nice next roll guys
tonight instead of spending it all on
random things what if instead you did
this
you by random things do you mean like
food and like
essentials water let's hear what you
have you you're saying you can buy
vertical debit spreads in the stock
market to actually grow your money in a
couple of weeks
you can do one for apple where you make
a thousand dollars with your six hundred
dollars in two weeks
isn't this the guy who's like hey you
need to have proper risk management this
is the guy this is definitely the guy
proper risk management proper risk
management
purple rush
he even posted i made a video about this
guy and he posted on my video oh i'm the
end of risk management
i believe in risk management i would
never encourage you know sloppy
investing i'm a man of risk management
he's telling you to try to turn 600 into
a thousand dollars in two weeks
risk management my ass dude you could
say he's a yolo trader but do not go
telling me hey he's risk management yeah
right
so you can do one for disney where you
can make a thousand four hundred dollars
which is 600
and you can even guys just 200x your
investment
no big deal no don't spit it on gas
don't spend it on
you know food gamble it guys go to the
casino roll your money away
even do one for amazon where you would
make a thousand dollars with your 600
in two weeks you can even join our
classroom to learn how to
sorry i don't even want of course right
he sells a class of course
so you first spin your your uh
stimulus money your stemi on his class
then you can go gamble it
nice uh what role is that was that nine
eight nine i don't know we'll play two
more and then we're done today
plan on just watching some tick tocks
today rule number nine just relaxing
psych do you know what i plan on doing
today
it starts with an ass and it ends with
the stocks
okay rule number nine um cocaine
what's rule number ten i'm gonna get
copyrighted israel number 10.
don't play that how do we reach in three
years minimum
hold ripple and don't listen to any
crypto news
are you guys dumb no dude
don't hold ripple guys please please
don't
hey it's a good chance it's going to
zero guys
we'll i mean we'll see i guess these
people are so dumb
wow well i guess those are your roles
i'll put them somewhere
editor put them on screen somewhere and
play my theme song and not that theme
song
all right guys uh that's basically it
today
tick tock investing learning stocks with
tick tocks i hope you enjoyed it hope
you learned or well i hope
you learned what not to do in fact this
is sort of a master class
in how not to behave you could almost
can almost learn a lot from tik-tok in
that sort of way whatever they tell you
to do whatever strategies they're
holding
maybe just take the exact opposite
position you're probably going to do
pretty well
uh but anyway yeah hope you enjoyed that
guys get in on the pump don't forget
hey pump right here join the pump
respect the pump
bow to the pump okay you want to be a
part of the pump the
the way you become a part of the pump is
very simple okay
and i'm gonna bless you with a rare we
don't use her very much anymore but an
ana anka outro and the original
outro to bless you with the pump the
truest pump let's get these numbers up
boys
ride it all the way coffeezilla to a
million in 2021
i can see it from here thank you for
watching guys
and i'll see you next time and don't
forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along